Усідороги мають бути проїзними не лише для коней
постановили майже рік тому жителі дев’яти селищ поблизу Ужгорода
Щоб не чекати від районної влади узгоджень та виділення коштів на ремонти доріг
вони на громадських слуханнях
розпочали процес об’єднання
в одну територіальну громаду –Баранинську
З центром в селищі Баранинці.
Це доволі заможний населений пункт
на відміну від його партнерів по громаді
Дороги там, важко то назвати це дорогами - напрямок і не більше
Вводопроводи занедбані
Садіки...
Також не на належному рівні.
Так само і школи, і клуби
В пріоритетному плані розвитку громади на першому місці
медицина та освіта
Передусім ремонт ось таких шкіл
А це в нас піч. В нас котел газовий накрився
А ще зламався і нещодавно відремонтований
за кошти районного бюджету туалет
Вчителька початкових класів Наталка Рогулич
працює в цій маленькій школі багато років
За весь час школа не дуже змінювалась, тут звикли жити скромно
Яне можу сказати
що нам було при районному керуванні погано
Як це буде, ніхто не знає. Надіємося, що будекраще
9 селищ, це 4 сільради
мали до об’єднання в своїх бюджетах усі разом
близько 34 мільйонів гривень
З усіх податків, що тут збирали, сільрадам залишали щонайбільше 10%
Після об’єднання
громада залишатиме в своєму бюджеті більше податків
і матиме близько
60 мільйонів гривень на власні потреби
Села будуть фінансуватися напряму з державного бюджету
60% податку на доходи фізосіб
буде йти напряму
у бюджет об’єднаної територіальної громади
Багато населених пунктів Закарпаття - дотаційні на 60-80%
Децентралізація дозволяє їм мати більше грошей
проте за 2 роки тут створили лише 5 громад
За оцінкамиЦентру розвитку місцевого самоврядування, процес йде не дуже жваво
Адже люди не завжди знають
що та як робити
В кожній об’єднаній і потенційній громаді
є відповідні різні коливання, різні роздуми
Десь там голова не дружить з радою, десь там рада хоче, а голова блокує
Це все треба роз’яснювати більше
і тільки за допомогою громадськості і інших ми можемо цей процес подолати
Центри розвитку місцевого самоврядування
створені в тому числі за підтримки уряду ФРН
є в кожному регіоні України
Громадські експерти працюють не лише з посадовцями
а й з жителями, інформують їх про переваги життя в об’єднаній громаді
Об’єднані села - це буде сильніша команда
Більший контроль за бюджетом, за розтратами коштів.
Це буде дуже добре.
Спільними зусиллями багато чого треба
в селі зробити
І дороги доробити до ума
І мало про пенсіонерівподбати
Баранинська громада знає про свій потенціал
Ця мальовнича місцевість із термальними джерелами
дуже приваблює туристів
Як цим скористатися на благо громади
мають придумати її нові керівники – голова і депутати
яких обирають 29 жовтня